hey Mako
I'm about to go grab some coffee you
want to join me yeah let's do it all
right let's go by the way before we
leave I want to say thank you just first
face for sponsoring today's video
whether you need a website or domain
make it whisper space
[Music]
so Mike oh I have a question for you all
right I've recently heard about this
thing called work-life balance yeah but
I have no idea what it is
could you explain it to me yeah so
where's my phones is the balance that an
individual needs between work and life
and so I think it's important to also
note that everyone has like a different
balance point so this really means some
things different every person okay okay
I I think that makes sense so like even
if I have a lot of work to do I should
still take time to take care of myself
yeah exactly
okay I mean I spend so much time working
how many hours a day do you work
so I usually work about like 40 hours a
week and
that's like you know Monday through
Friday nine five
what's more important is like the
emphasis on getting what I need to get
done yeah so it doesn't matter like how
much time I put into it because it's
more like outcome than effort right
right yeah cool okay makes sense makes
sense
you work 9:00 to 5:00 you said I do yeah
so like are you working that whole time
or do you take breaks I definitely take
breaks even if I'm working an eight-hour
day I can't possibly code for eight
hours straight because I mean my brain
to refresh everyone's mellow and so
usually I'll work like either 20 minutes
or a couple hours basically until they
get stuck or tired yeah then I'll take
like a quick five to 15 minute breaks to
refresh myself so they're definitely
great so I don't have to be like
interesting okay cuz like whenever I see
programmers on TV and stuff they're kind
of working really long hours with no
breaks and wearing hoodies and drinking
sugary drinks
yeah and that's definitely one way the
software engineers have been depicted
overtime in the media but yeah that's
really not what my kind of day-to-day is
like at all it kind of was when I was in
college when I had to study a lot but
you know nowadays when I'm working a
full-time job that's really the case
okay so what about when you like don't
get your work done on time do you work
nights and weekends to catch up I
sometimes do and that's actually really
rare it's more like a self-imposed thing
and anything like no one's telling me or
anything so much as it is like I just
want to be able to finish my work and so
sometimes I'll put in a couple extra
hours at night or work on weekends but
generally that's not the case and so
maybe like I'll work say five weekends a
year to like catch up on any work when
it's French
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for the coffee my you go anything
else I should know
yeah I would say that like everyone has
a different work life balance point I
would say so it's really important when
talking about work-life balance is to be
empathetic terminal situation everyone
has two different max to what they can
do and so it's really good to not
enforce what your max is on other suits
and just like talking about it and
communicating to be empathetic so
there's equal situations which is going
to make everything a lot easier that's
the only thing I would say
yeah hey yeah okay well thanks Micha
I've got to run to a meeting so I'll
catch you later yeah bye
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching today's video if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up and hopefully
I answered a lot of the questions that
you have about work-life balance but if
I have not then leave a comment down
below don't forget to hit the subscribe
button for new videos and I wanted to
take a moment to say thank you again to
Squarespace for sponsoring today's video
so as I mentioned in my last video I
think that there is a little bit of a
pressure to like make your own website
and stuff but you know given you know
where your work/life balance point is
that maybe you are really busy with
other stuff and you don't have time to
make your own website
I think Squarespace is a great solution
to that problem they have beautiful
designer templates that are ready to go
for you and it's an all-in-one platform
so you never have to install upgrade or
patch anything which means way less work
for you they have award-winning 24/7
customer service so if you're a morning
person that you work on it at 6 a.m. or
if you're a night owl you are going to
add 2 a.m. and you run into a bug then
there are customer reps ready to help
you out it's easy to set up or transfer
a domain on Squarespace so you can brand
it with whatever you would like which is
really cool and they also have an online
store so if you want to set up your own
merch line that you can also do that
through Squarespace so head to
Squarespace com for your free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace com /my you go for 10% off
your first purchase off a domain or
website cool well that's it for today
I'll see you next time bye Senay dislike
drink sugary drinks
I'm just excited to drink this coffee